(upbeat music)
Hi, it's Eitan Bernath and like Drew
I love trying food from all different cities,
all over the United States whenever I travel.
And our friends at Eater want to show us three amazing spots
for next time you are out and about for you to try.
Let's check them out.
(upbeat music)
(airplane engine roaring)
Hey Drew, my name's Brooke Jackson-Glidden,
I'm the editor of Eater Portland,
and I'm at one of my all time favorite restaurants
in Portland, Han Oak.
(upbeat music)
Han Oak opened six years ago.
We had to close for the past couple years
but we reopened with an exciting new menu of hot pot.
It's communal, I love that it serves as a canvas
for our mix of Korean, barbecue,
Japanese Shabu Shabu, Chinese hot pot.
And it's really just getting to share a meal
around this communal pot.
We start off with a big plate of shaved meats,
local vegetables, and then once people are done with that
we kind of transition into a dumpling and noodle course.
It's really fun and interactive and delicious.
(upbeat music)
(airplane engine roaring)
Hi Drew I'm Tierny, Eater Baltimore's editor.
I'm here at one of my favorite spots in the city,
Cindy Lou's Fish House,
with chef and owner Cindy Wolf herself.
Hi Drew.
I worked in Charleston, South Carolina
at the beginning of my career,
and I love low country cooking.
I kind of went back to our roots with this concept
having all the wonderful crab and rockfish
and oysters and beautiful things that our waterways produce,
serving it and making you feel comfortable
and happy and enjoying a great view.
Well, the food is incredible, the atmosphere is lovely.
Thank you for having us.
Bye Drew. Thank you.
I'll see you soon.
Thank you, Drew.
(upbeat music)
(airplane engine roaring)
Hey Drew, it's Olee, the editor of Eater Miami.
And today I'm at one of my favorite restaurants in town
Boia De!
with the co-owner Alex, who's gonna tell us a little bit
about this beautiful restaurant.
What sets us apart is that with our extensive background
of fine dining cuisine that we can bring these ingredients
and these techniques that you don't really find
in these neighborhood restaurants
and put it in this package of something really cute
and affordable and approachable.
Where you're not intimidated by some big blitzy thing
And you can just get these nice things like caviar,
foie gras, slightly different meats, like rabbit,
fresh pasta and feel at home
while getting to enjoy these things and feel comfortable.
Those restaurants look amazing.
I hope to see you there.
(upbeat music)